I am an architect
that all of my life so I'm live
for me being an architect means three
specific things one is teaching so I've
been a member of the faculty at Carnegie
Mellon since 1981 the second is doing
research I've been a part of the Center
for building performance and diagnostics
since 1988 and was the project manager
for our flagship building research lab
the intelligent workplace and the third
piece is practice so I have the ideal
circumstance in that I can do all three
of those things simultaneously and I
find that each one informs the other and
I think makes me more effective as an
architect I firmly believe in the power
of education as a way of taking the
things that I believe in broadening the
number of people who are practicing that
way so I've always tried to be as an
educator someone who inspires my
students to achieve lofty goals one of
the exercises that I have my students do
in my zero energy house class is to
design a building that achieves the
German Passivhaus standard and just to
give you a metric on that the typical
McMansion in the United States consumes
about a hundred and 50 kilowatt hours
per meter squared of occupied space per
year a low-energy house and that that so
that's meeting the current energy code
in the United States 150 kilowatt-hours
meter squared per year a low-energy
house according to the German standard
consumes 30 kilowatt hours per meter
squared per year so reduction of five
times and to meet the Passivhaus
standard in Germany your heating load
has to be less than 15 kilowatt hours
per meter squared per year so a factor
of ten times and it's it's doable so
it's not futuristic it's not
pie-in-the-sky ideas I've often been
asked what would it take to make my
building green obviously as an architect
this is a question that I get asked many
many times in the extreme the three
points that I would make
that the building needs to be zero
energy it needs to be zero carbon and it
needs to be zero water is that
achievable only in the rarest of
circumstances but it really clearly
establishes a goal that we can all
aspire to